ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen zum
ersten Mal gibt es im Westen Kritik an
der ukrainischen Armee ganz zum ersten
Mal kann man nicht sagen seit ein paar
Wochen gibt es die schon aber jetzt gibt
es sie offenbar auch in einem internen
Bericht der Bundeswehr einige Experten
haben schon seit ein paar Wochen gesagt
dass offenbar manches nicht so läuft wie
sich manche westliche Verbündete das
vorstellen und vor allem geht es bei der
Kredit da Kritik darum dass die Ukrainer
nicht die Taktiken anwenden die der
Westen offenbar empfiehlt wie wird das
vor Ort gesehen das fragen wir gleich
unseren Reporter in der Ukraine der war
schon sehr viel an der Front unterwegs
hat mit vielen Soldaten und Soldaten
gesprochen und was deren Sicht auf die
Dinge ist darüber sprechen wir gleich
die Kritik von der wir gerade schon
gehört haben die ist nicht nur unfair so
ein bisschen von der Seitenlinie sondern
sie ist vor allem auch unberechtigt sagt
unser heutiger Gesprächspartner im
Stream und das ist Nico lange Größe sie
hat lange schön dass Sie bei uns dabei
sind
guten abend noch mal ganz kurz zur
Vorstellung sie betreiben den
zeitenwende-podcast der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz sie waren zuvor
Leiter des leitungsstabs im
Verteidigungsministerium und sie haben
lange in Russland und auch in der
Ukraine gelebt und gearbeitet unter
anderem für die Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung
wir blicken gleich Punkt für Punkt auf
die geäußerte Kritik aber was stört Sie
denn daran ganz grundsätzlich
grundsätzlich richtig auch Kritik zu
üben die Ukrainer selbst und auch in den
ukrainischen Streitkräften gibt es
einige die Vorgehensweisen der
ukrainischen Armee kritisieren aber
gleichzeitig muss man festhalten diese
Situation wie wir sie in der Südukraine
sehen mit Drohnen die überall präsent
sind mit sehr weiter Sichtbarkeit in
sehr flachen Gelände und vor allen
Dingen mit diesen sehr ausgedehnten
Minenfeldern die zudem noch ständig
gemanagt werden also neue Minen werden
verlegt diese Situation kennen westliche
Streitkräfte auch die Bundeswehr bisher
nicht und es ist fraglich ob es denn
stimmen würde dass wenn man nur die von
der Bundeswehr geraten den
Einsatzgrundsätze anwenden würde dass
dann diese Gegenoffensive bessere
Fortschritte machen würde daran habe ich
meine
hier gibt es schon die erste Zustimmung
in den Chats hier schreibt einen User
auf Youtube genauer lange erst zu wenig
Waffen dann die falschen Waffen
geliefert und jetzt nur noch meckern
also hier kommt Zustimmung in den Chats
was ist ihre Meinung eure Meinung
schreibt uns gerne in die Kommentare
oder wenn ihr die App nutzt an die
eingeblendete E-Mail-Adresse ZDF
heute-live@zdf.de bevor wir das jetzt
Punkt für Punkt bearbeiten schauen wir
uns mal an worum es denn eigentlich geht
im Detail Jan Schüssler hat das
zusammengefasst
seit mehreren Wochen läuft die
ukrainische gegen Offensive Beobachter
beschreiben den Fortschritt als langsam
und stetig einen entscheidenden
Durchbruch konnte die ukrainische Armee
bisher aber nicht erzielen
Militärexperten aus verschiedenen
Ländern hatten zuletzt die Front besucht
darunter der österreichische
militäranalyst Franz Stefan Gady der
Einsatz war schlecht geplant und
organisiert es gab eine mangelnde
Koordination der vorstoßenden Einheiten
vor allem in der ersten Phase der Gegend
Offensive sieht der militäranalyst
Fehler aufgehobener Ebene innerhalb der
ukrainischen Streitkräfte die
Bild-Zeitung zitiert nun aus einem
internen Papier der Bundeswehr darin
kritisiert diese die ukrainische Armee
deutlich
in vielen Fällen wurde festgestellt dass
Soldaten ohne jüngere Kampf oder
militärerfahrung durch die erhaltene
militärische
ausbildungsunterstützung größere
Ausbildungserfolge erzielen als
vermeintlich erfahrene und ausgebildete
Soldaten Kampf Erfahrung bedeutet
demnach laut Bundeswehr nicht dass der
Soldat ein guter Anführer im Gefecht sei
vor allem die im Westen gelernten
Kriegstechniken würden nicht adäquat
angewendet werden die Ukraine habe ihre
leeren gezogen meint Gady die Offensive
werde aber wahrscheinlich deutlich
länger dauern als gedacht
ja lange dann lassen Sie uns mal Punkt
für Punkt das besprechen und mit dem
ersten Kritikpunkt beginnen der Einsatz
war schlecht geplant und organisiert
können Sie das nachvollziehen
es gibt immer wieder Berichte darüber
dass es Abstimmungsprobleme gibt
zwischen ukrainischen Einheiten dass die
Kommunikation nicht funktioniert und das
insbesondere die Abstimmung zwischen
infanteriemechanisierten Kräften und
Artillerie nur schwierig gelingt es gibt
auch sehr unterschiedliche Qualitäten
der ukrainischen Einheiten und einige
sind da offensichtlich besser dazu in
der Lage das zu tun und andere haben da
große Schwierigkeiten und gleichzeitig
sind die ukrainischen Einheiten mit
Rahmenbedingungen konfrontiert die einen
organisiertes Gefecht sehr sehr
schwierig machen also vor allen Dingen
dieses sehr flache Gelände im Süden wo
jede Bewegung der Ukraine von den Russen
auf Kilometer Entfernung wir sehen wird
und die Minenfelder über die wir schon
gesprochen haben diese
Abstimmungsprobleme haben auch damit zu
tun dass die Ukraine sehr gut darin ist
kleine Formationen einzusetzen aber
offensichtlich Schwierigkeiten damit hat
viele kleine Informationen
zusammenzubringen zu einem großen
organisierten Angriff das war vorher
schon bekannt und das ist offensichtlich
immer noch ein Problem die Ukraine
musste aber jetzt ihre Vorgehensweise in
der Gegend Offensive auch anpassen und
geht jetzt anders vor als zum Anfang und
ich glaube wir werden da jetzt stetige
zwar langsamer aber stetige Erfolge
sehen
ich gucke hier mal gerade in die Chats
und sehe das viele Userinnen und User
das umtreibt dass die Waffen sehr spät
geliefert wurden hier schreibt einer
alles zu spät bekommen und zu wenig und
ein anderer schreibt liefert endlich
alle Waffen die sie brauchen dann wird
es viel schneller laufen und eine Frage
dazu direkt an Sie welche Waffen waren
falsch und welche wären die richtigen
ist das dynamische Minenfelder also
Minenfelder die gemanagt werden durch
die Russen ein großes militärisches
Hindernis darstellen das sind nicht die
Minenfelder die man vielleicht aus dem
Übungsgeschehen bei der Bundeswehr kennt
wo sie 200 x 200 m groß sind sondern das
Minenfelder die viele Quadratkilometer
groß sind und in denen Russland mit
Minenwerfern neue Minen verlegt wenn die
Ukraine an anderer Stelle welche
wegräumt oder sprengt das ist ein großes
Problem und die Ukraine hat zu wenig
Gerätschaften um Minen zu beseitigen
Minen zu springen
und da haben wir einfach alle
miteinander das geht ja nicht nur um die
Bundeswehr bei weitem nicht sondern alle
Partner der Ukraine zu wenig von diesem
Equipment geliefert und vielleicht auch
zu wenig Erfahrung mit dieser Art von
modernen Minenfeldern und was die
Artillerie betrifft ist die Ukraine
schon den ganzen Krieg über unterlegen
und versucht das auszugleichen durch
Präzision aber hat Probleme damit
infektionsnachschub zu organisieren die
Ukraine produziert selbst
Artilleriemunition jetzt wieder ein
größerem Umfang das hat eine Weile
gedauert damit das anläuft aber gerade
bei den europäischen Partnern ist sehr
viel über munitionsproduktion geliefert
worden sind auch Papiere produziert
worden Munition produziert und geliefert
worden ist allerdings noch nicht im
richtigen Umfang und das macht die
Ukraine natürlich schwächer wenn sie
nicht bei der Artillerie entgegengewicht
zu der sehr starken Artillerie der
Russen aufbauen kann jetzt hat die
Ukraine sich darauf konzentriert mit
kleinen Angriffen das wird ja auch
kritisiert aber das scheint mir ein
logisches Vorgehen zu sehen mit sehr
kleinen Angriffen immer wieder die
russische Artillerie herauszulocken um
dann Stück für Stück jedes einzelne
Geschütz jeder einzelne Haubitze zu
bekämpfen um dann bessere
Voraussetzungen zu haben für größere
Angriffe zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt
schreibt hier in einem Kommentar man
verlangt viel von der Ukraine aber
schränkt sie dennoch ein lassen Sie uns
den zweiten Punkt mal ansprechen der
gerade im Stück genannt wurde die
Kriegstechniken die der Westen den
Soldaten beigebracht hat werden nicht
adäquat angewendet was sagen sie dazu
an der ukrainische erfahrene Soldat
der bezweifelt vielleicht ein wenig ob
die Bundeswehr ihm den Kriegstechniken
beibringen kann weil er sich im
Zweifelsfall seit zehn Jahren im Krieg
befindet viele Einsätze im Donbass
gemacht hat und jetzt in diesem Krieg
steht und die Bundeswehr aus der
Perspektive eines Kampf erfahrenen
ukrainischen Soldaten doch vor allen
Dingen Theorie anzubieten hat also sie
selbst solche Gefechte der verbundenen
Waffen nie geführt hat weil sie ihre
eigenen Einsatz Grundsätze nie in der
Praxis ausprobieren musste und da ist es
natürlich für den ukrainischen
Kommandeur schwer jetzt zu sagen ich
vertraue jetzt diesen theoretischen
Ansätzen mehr als meiner Kampf Erfahrung
aus den letzten zehn Jahren und im
Zweifelsfall sitzt er dann auch das
Wasser in den letzten 10 Jahren gelernt
und gemacht hat also dieser Umstieg ich
kann das verstehen warum das schwierig
ist ich finde auch dass Analysten die
Kritik gerne anbringen sollen und es ist
auch richtig dass man auf Schwachpunkte
hinweist wenn man gleichzeitig sich
überlegt wie kann in diese Schwachpunkte
ausgleichen was kann man eigentlich
selbst dazu beitragen dass es besser
wird man sollte sich also nicht darüber
beschweren dass die Ukraine nicht so
kämpfen wie die Bundeswehr Ihnen das
beibringen wollte sondern man sollte
sich überlegen wie kann man das
unterstützen und wie kann man vielleicht
auch die Einsatzgrundsätze der
Bundeswehr verbessern damit sie unter
diesen Bedingungen in diesen flachen
Land mit diesen vielen Drohnen mit der
gegen den gegnerischen Übergewicht bei
Artillerie ohne Luft Überlegenheit zu
Ergebnissen führen können das Thema
Luftüberlegenheit oder Luftabwehr
Flugabwehr wird auch hier in den Chats
kommentiert und ich sehe auch dass viele
Userinnen und User schreiben dass unser
Bild unscharf ist wir versuchen
rauszufinden woran das hier liegt wenn
das denn da draußen bei euch so ankommt
wissen wir gerade nicht versuchen wir
aber natürlich zu beheben Herr Lange wir
sind gleich wieder bei ihnen ich möchte
aber gerne auch das was sie mitgemacht
mit was Sie gerade schon gesagt haben
mitnehmen in die Ukraine zu unserem
Reporter dort vor Ort und das ist daran
Hass er ist jetzt gerade für uns in Kiew
war aber auch schon viel im Land
unterwegs im Süden des Landes war auch
an den Frontabschnitten und hat dort mit
vielen Soldatinnen und Soldaten
gesprochen wie sind die Reaktionen auf
diesen Bericht
die Reaktionen sind sehr sehr leise das
wurde hier eigentlich fast nicht
wahrgenommen wahrscheinlich auch
deswegen weil diese Diskussion wie man
vorgehen soll wie man kämpfen soll wann
man wie viel westliche Waffen denn
einsetzen soll schon lange auch hier in
der Ukraine unter den Menschen geführt
wird aber auch unter den
militäranalysten
saluschni der Oberbefehlshaber hat
selber ungefähr vor einer Woche gesagt
der Westen würde nie so kämpfen und
damit meinte er dass sie der Westen im
Verbund angreifen würde aber er hat
nicht ausreichend Kampfjet nämlich vor
allem viel zu wenige die aus dem Westen
geliefert wurden und auch dazu wenig
ausgebildete Piloten anderer Freund von
saporischer habe ich lange mit einem
Soldaten gesprochen immer wieder der
erzählt hat seine einfach seine Einheit
hatte vor der gegen Offensive bevor sie
begann drei Bradleys bekommen relativ
früh in der Gegenoffensive wurden zwei
beschädigt einer war dem Kommandanten
vorbehalten was natürlich unter den
befreiten jetzt auch nicht
Freudensprünge hervorruft aber
wahrscheinlich in allen Armeen
prinzipiell der Fall ist das Offiziere
auch besonders geschützt sind weil sie
ja von einem Kampfabschnitt zum anderen
gehen dieser diese diese Änderungen der
Taktik die hat er am eigenen Leiber
erlebt sie sind da nicht mehr mit den
ähm gepanzerten Einheiten vor sondern
erzählte sondern wirklich in kleinen
Gruppen und oft hat die Artillerie
Unterstützung gefehlt er hatte große
Hoffnungen wie die Streumunition
angekündigt wurde von den Amerikanern
dass das die Unterlegenheit in seinem in
seiner Einheit was die Artillerie angeht
reduzieren könnte
es ist leider so gewesen dass er gestern
von einer von einem minenschrapell
getroffen wurde und jetzt im
Militärkrankenhaus von saporea ist er
hat also dieses er ist außer
Lebensgefahr aber er hat diese
Entwicklung dieser Gegend Offensive von
Anfang an miterlebt und
beschreibt eigentlich diese Erfahrungen
und diese Diskussionen am eigenen Leibe
ziemlich exakt so und daran das Beispiel
zeigt natürlich auch worum es am Ende
geht nämlich um Menschen die verletzt
verwundet und getötet werden und da gab
es auch ein Zitat vom Oberbefehlshaber
der ukrainischen Armee General
saluschnee der hat vor kurzem gesagt es
macht mich wütend diese Kritik aus dem
Ausland und die Kritik an den
Streitkräften der Washington Post hat er
gesagt das ist hier keine Show bei der
die ganze Welt zuschaut und Wetten
abschließt oder so jeder Tag jeder Meter
wird mit Blut bezahlt
ja das ist genau der Fall und auch
andere Soldaten haben uns erzählt wie
alleine sie da vorne sind in diesen
Minenfeldern ohne ausreichende
Luftunterstützung ohne minenräumpanzer
und das unter stetigen Beschuss von
einer Seite die sich wirklich
monatelang vorbereitet hat die
Verteidigungslinien angelegt hat und
auch wusste welche Art von Waffen der
Westen liefert und welche auch nicht
weswegen z.B Kampfhubschrauber aus
relativ sicherer Entfernung ihre
Geschosse absetzen können und deshalb
sieht wahrscheinlich die Militärführung
der Ukraine keine Alter an der
Alternative zu kleinen Einheiten für die
Soldaten selbst für das natürlich auch
zu Kritik an ihren direkten Vorgesetzten
oder an den ähm mittleren offiziersren
die Ihnen diese Aufträge geben dass sie
jetzt eine Stellung einnehmen sollen
obwohl im Verbund keine Unterstützung
herrscht ver schon in den
Oberbefehlshaber ist in der Ukraine aber
sowohl unter den Soldaten den Offizieren
und in der gesamten Bevölkerung gegeben
saluschnee steht außer jedem Zweifel
aufgrund seiner Leistung
zeitkriegsbeginn
inwiefern gibt es aber denn auch
innerhalb der Armee Kritik vielleicht
nicht am Oberbefehlshaber aber schon an
dem wie die Armee davor geht wird das
auch in Frage gestellt hast du das auch
erlebt
nee also so ich habe immer nur mit
einzelnen
Soldaten oder Kommandeuren sprechen die
sprechen können die an ihrem Front
abschritt erzählt haben unter was sie
gerade live
leiden oder weil wo sie Vorteile haben
wie wir in bachmut waren z.B da hat er
Militärarzt
beschrieben wie seine
Militärärzte permanent beschossen werden
ein richtiges als richtiges
militärisches Ziel betrachtet werden was
natürlich die Moral der kämpfenden
Truppe vorne an der Front enorm
reduzieren kann und beeinträchtigten
wenn man nämlich weiß dass die die
feldler zerrente nicht mehr
funktionieren dann sind ja auch weniger
schlimme Verletzungen die aber versorgt
werden müssen lebensgefährlich ähm
andere haben erzählt sie Leopard das
scheint eine sehr geschützte Tierart zu
sein sie haben noch keinen gesehen wo
sie in einer Panzer die wissen
sind
andererseits gibt es auch wiederum ein
Wulle da hatten wir erlebt wo sie uns
erzählt hatten wir haben jetzt neue
Artillerie und neue Munition und es ist
ein anderer Klang in unseren Ohren
genaue Details geben natürlich die
Militärs nicht Preis
daran eine letzte Frage noch an dich
weil viele das hier auch interessiert
nämlich das Thema Luftabwehr Flugabwehr
muss es heißen hier schreibt ein User
über Youtube das liegt daran dass man
Taktiken empfiehlt die man nur bei
eigener Luft Überlegenheit durchführen
kann welche Rolle spielt das Thema Luft
Flugabwehr in der ukrainischen Armee
sie spielt eine riesenrolle in der
ukrainischen Armee und zwar genau darum
geht's dass er ist genau richtig
beschrieben dass wenn man mit
mechanisierten Einheiten vielleicht auch
mit Leopard Panzern an einem
Frontabschnitt angreifen will dass man
dort eine lokale Luft Überlegenheit
braucht wir kommen jetzt gerade heute
aus Odessa und der der Hafen wurde
beschossen auch dort fehlt Luftabwehr
diese permanenten Beschüsse der der
Städte in der Ukraine führt natürlich
auch dazu dass die ukrainische Armee
jetzt ihre Luft abwehreinheiten nicht
oder flugabwehreinheiten nicht an der
Front konzentrieren können denn sonst
sind äh ist das Hinterland ungeschützt
das sind die Schwierigkeiten vor denen
die ukrainische Armee steht und Frau
romaniok die Militärsprecherin der
Südfront der sagte mir vor zwei Tagen
nur besser das ist unser Hauptproblem
wir haben nicht genug Patriots
vielen Dank daran dass du bei uns in der
Sendung warst und wieder direkt aus der
Ukraine für uns berichtet hast danke
schön
und damit gehen wir wieder zurück zu
Nico lange dem militär-experten der auch
sehr genau die frontverläufe immer im
Blick hat und beobachtet bevor wir
vielleicht dann noch im weiteren Verlauf
des Gesprächs über ihren Blick auf die
frontverläufe und die Erfolge der
ukrainischen Armee so gering sie denn
auch sein mögen blicken lassen Sie uns
noch mal bei den Kritikpunkten bleiben
wir haben gerade gelernt dass es vor
allem auf
höheren Ebenen so lautet die Kritik
Fehler gemacht dass dort Fehler gemacht
worden auf welchen Ebenen sehen Sie
möglicherweise Lernpotenzial
das ist so dass die Ukraine mit
kleineren Einheiten und mit der
taktischen Ebene besser zurechtkommt als
mit größeren Einheiten und einer
strategischen Ebene man merkt das ab der
Ebene der Brigade die Visionen hat die
Ukraine irgendwann mal abgeschafft das
ist schwer fällt die unterschiedlichen
Einheiten zu koordinieren und gemeinsam
zur Wirkung zu bringen die Ukraine ist
aber jetzt in einem Gefecht dass
möglicherweise zu diesem Zeitpunkt
solche größeren Angriffe auch gar nicht
möglich macht weil ohne Luft
Überlegenheit in Minenfeldern in
ausgedehnten flachen Land man sonst mit
diesen großen Einheiten im Grunde auf
dem Präsentierteller stehen würde also
muss es zunächst einmal darum gehen die
Artillerie des Gegners zu dezimieren die
Logistik die führungs- und
Kommunikationseinrichtungen zu schwächen
und genau das sehen wir ja gerade mit
den Storm Shadow Angriffen auf die Krim
wo jeden Tag Munitionsdepots angegriffen
werden und mit dem gezielten Ausschalten
der Artillerie das zumindest bei
russischen Militär beobachten und schon
dazu geführt hat dass sie gesagt haben
dieses dezimieren der russischen
Artillerie durch die Ukraine das hat
System das schwächt die Russen und das
wird am Ende vielleicht zu einem
Zusammenbruch der russischen Front
führen
hier ist eine Frage an Sie wenn die
Ukraine die f16-jets bekommt dann werden
sie ja auch Waffen dafür benötigen
werden dann höchstwahrscheinlich Raketen
mit größerer Reichweite geliefert
zunächst mal muss man glaube ich
festhalten die F16 kommen spät so wie
auch die Schützen und Kampfpanzer spät
kommen und leider haben die Partner der
Ukraine auch Deutschland noch immer
nicht erkannt wie dringlich die Dinge
sind und das zahlt nicht unendlich
vorhanden ist und es ist schon sehr sehr
frustrierend für die Ukraine die da im
Gefecht stehen dass die Prozesse bei uns
immer so ewig lange dauern hätte man die
Schützen und Kampfpanzer früher
entschieden dann hätte auch die Ukraine
mehr Zeit gehabt zum Beispiel das
Gefecht der verbundenen Waffen zu üben
das muss man bei dem Beurteilungen eben
mit einstiegen lassen bei den F16 ist es
so dass die sehr helfen würden sowohl
gegen die Kampfhubschrauber und die
russische Luftwaffe als auch für die
Unterstützung der Truppen am Boden und
dass die F16 natürlich bewaffnet werden
müssen das ist klar wird mich freuen
wenn auch die Bundeswehr dazu beiträgt
oder die Bundesrepublik Deutschland dazu
beiträgt mit den Taurus nachtflugkörpern
die Briten haben ja Sturm Shadow
geliefert die jetzt von ukrainischen
Flugzeugen aus abgefeuert werden
und die Franzosen skulpijay und wenn wir
Taurus liefern könnten würde das helfen
ich glaube das ist technisch machbar
sein wird die zum Beispiel von den F16
aus abzufeuern die Reichweiten die damit
erreicht Weichen werden können reichen
aus um das zu tun was die Ukraine tun
muss nämlich die Logistik die Führung
und Kommunikation der Russen anzugreifen
so dass dann die Voraussetzungen da sind
für Durchbrüche und um die Creme unter
Druck zu setzen es geht ja gar nicht
darum die Creme zum Beispiel zu erobern
sonst geht darum sie unter Druck zu
setzen sie vom Nachschub abzuschneiden
das halte ich für möglich ich bin auch
grundsätzlich weiter optimistisch dass
der Ukraine ein Durchbruch gelingen wird
an der Front es geht nur eben viel
langsamer als das viele erwartet haben
weil eben diese Durchbrüche schnell
nicht gelungen sind und jetzt diese ganz
akribische langsame Vorgehensweise
gewählt werden muss das verstehe ich
dass das viele frustriert und dass man
da schneller auf Ergebnisse wartet aber
die beste Handhabe die wir haben ist auf
langfristige Unterstützung jetzt zu
setzen systematisch und mit
Unterstützung der Industrie dann wird
der Ukraine glaube ich auch noch viel
gelingen
einen Punkt möchte ich gerne noch
rausgreifen nämlich die Kritik daran
dass das gelieferte Gerät nicht im
Verbund eingesetzt wird und dazu haben
wir die Kritik auch noch mal
zusammengefasst
manche Sicherheitsexperten erklären den
Verlauf der Offensive aus politischen
Gründen damit dass der Westen zu wenig
liefere aber das sind nicht immer
militäranalysten die Einsicht in die
Lage vor Ort haben deshalb möchte ich
die monokausale Erklärung nicht so
stehen lassen der Verlauf der Offensive
erklärt sich vor allem daraus dass das
gelieferte Gerät nicht im Verbund
eingesetzt wurde wo das einzelne System
seine Fähigkeiten am besten entfalten
kann das würde im Übrigen auch für die
geforderte Lieferung von Kampfflugzeugen
gelten ohne effektiven Kampf der
verbundenen Waffen würde auch das
Potenzial solcher Waffen nicht voll
ausgeschöpft werden können
also dass die Meinung von Herrn Gady
Birgit Unland schreibt auf Youtube die
Bundeswehr hätte mit dem mickrigen
Waffenarsenal der Ukraine doch keine
drei Monate eine 1.300 m Front Stand
gehalten also nicht meckern sondern
unterstützen ist der Kommentar von Frau
Unland die Frage des Einsatzes von
Geräten im Verbund hat der Experte da
recht
oder von Geräten von Sie wissen was ich
meine
ja er hat recht also die die Ukraine ist
nicht in der Lage das Gefecht der
verbundenen Waffen so zu führen wie es
das Maximum aus den einzelnen
Waffensystemen herausholen könnte die
Ukraine hatte schlicht und einfach keine
Zeit das zu üben und zu trainieren und
auch dafür viel Übung man braucht dafür
viel Kommunikation man braucht Erfahrung
und im Idealfall auch Einheiten die
schon lange zusammen sind wo das gleiche
Personal über längere Zeiträume diese
Dinge übt und dann auch miteinander in
den Einsatz geht aber diese
Voraussetzungen waren in der Ukraine
eben nicht da weil wir spät geliefert
haben weil die Ukraine Verluste erleiden
weil die Einheiten nicht so zusammen
bleiben insofern ist es finde ich ein
bisschen auch eine Diskussion zwischen
Theorie und Praxis und die Praxis dieses
Krieges ist eben nicht so wie sie am
Reißbrett oder auf dem Übungsplatz
wünschenswert wäre die Ukraine müssen
damit zurechtkommen und wir müssen
überlegen wie wir unter diesen realen
Bedingungen die Ukrainer weiter
unterstützen selbst wenn Ihnen das
Gefecht der verbundenen Waffen nicht so
gelingt wie es vielleicht wünschenswert
wäre das werden die jetzt während des
Krieges während der laufenden Offensive
nicht üben können oder nur beschränkt
verbessern können aber trotzdem wird die
Ukraine ja die ganze Zeit an sich
arbeiten um bessere Erfolge zu erzielen
man muss ja am besten aufpassen dass man
nicht so ein bisschen so ein
überheblichen Sound bekommt wo man so
den Eindruck erweckt die Ukraine
sozusagen würden mit Absicht schlecht
kämpfen oder mit Absicht die Hinweise
oder die Beratung der Partner ignorieren
wenn man andere Streitkräfte in dem Fall
die ukrainischen Streitkräfte berät muss
man glaube ich auch ganz nüchtern damit
leben dass die diese Ratschläge entweder
beachten oder teilweise beachten oder
dass sie eben das tun was sie für
richtig halten da sollte man nicht
beleidigt sein wenn die nicht das machen
was man für richtig hält
jetzt ist es natürlich
Interpretationssache ob die Bundeswehr
beleidigt ist oder nicht was wir wissen
ist dass es dieses interne Papier gibt
in dem man erstmal feststellt wie es
läuft und welche Schlüsse man daraus
zieht das wird man sehen aber dann
lassen wir uns doch hinten raus
versuchen irgendwie konstruktiv zu
werden wenn man feststellt ist läuft
nicht so gut wie es laufen sollte das
stellen die Ukrainer sehr sehr
schmerzhaft fest denn Sie bezahlen jeden
dieser Fehler mit Blut und das Stellen
andere Armeen fest die versuchen die
Ukraine zu unterstützen wie kann die
Zusammenarbeit den konkret besser werden
das dringendste ist die Frage wie kann
man mit diesen gemanagten Minenfeldern
umgehen kann man mehr Gerätschaften
liefern um Minen zu sprengen Minen zu
zerstören gibt es vielleicht auch neue
Ideen wie man mit diesen Minenfeldern
umgehen kann das ist ein ganz großes
Problem das ja alles andere aufhält und
das Gefecht der verbundenen Muffin kann
man ja nicht gegen einen Minenfeld
führen sondern gegen den Gegner aber
dafür muss man an den Gegner überhaupt
erst mal herankommen und dafür müssen
die Minen weg also das scheint mir das
größte Problem zu sein wir haben ja auch
gesehen als die Ukraine die ersten
Vorstöße versucht haben dass sie im
Grunde wie auf dem präsentiert werden
Teller in diesem Minenfeldern steckten
und dann von den Kampfhubschraubern
bekämpft wurden also da neue Rezepte zu
finden mehr Equipment zu liefern das ist
glaube ich ein wichtiger nächster
Schritt und dann andere nächster Schritt
ist die Russen werden besser im Einsatz
von Drohnen es gibt überall Drohnen an
dieser Frontlinie und den Ukraine
Instrumen Inseln in die Hand zu geben um
drinnen Abwehr entweder mit
elektromagnetischen Waffen oder mit
kinetischen Waffen durchzuführen das
scheint mir im Moment ganz wichtig zu
sein weil wenn man nicht sich bewegen
kann ohne dass man gesehen wird wenn man
permanent beobachtet wird von den
russischen Drohnen und viele der Drohnen
sind auch bewaffnet wenn man da ständig
bedroht wird dann ist es noch
schwieriger Dinge zu entfalten und zu
einem vernünftigen Aufbau des eigenen
Gefecht zu kommen also ich glaube da
gibt es einiges was man tun kann Minen
und Drohnen scheinen mir besonders
wichtig und dann ist doch klar Nachschub
bei Munition die industrielle
Unterstützung insbesondere bei
Artillerie Munition die ist noch nicht
so wie sie sein müsste da muss der
Westen dringend die
Produktionskapazitäten erhöhen damit man
Munition produziert und direkt in die
Ukraine bringt also das sind schon mal
drei Dinge die man jetzt tun kann alles
besser als zuzuschauen und das zu tun
was der ukrainische Oberbefehlshaber
saluschni ja zurecht kritisiert hat so
zu tun als sei das jetzt etwas wo wir
nur zu gucken wir haben Interesse daran
dass die Ukraine diesen Krieg gewinnt
und deswegen müssen wir immer überlegen
was wir tun können
letzte Frage an sie hat lange wie
schätzen sie denn aktuell die Offensive
der Ukraine ein
die Fortschritte sind gering vor allen
Dingen im Vergleich zu den Erwartungen
die ersten Schritte mit erwarteten
schnellen Durchbrüchen sind nicht
gelungen das muss man festhalten es gibt
viele Schwierigkeiten und wir haben über
einige gesprochen und dennoch sind die
Fortschritte ja jetzt stetig auch wenn
Sie mit diesem kleinen Einheiten
erreicht werden und ich glaube die
Dezimierung der Artillerie und der
Einsatz gegen Logistik und gegen
führungskommunikationseinrichtungen der
russischen Seite ist ein
vielversprechender weg ich halte es für
sehr wahrscheinlich dass der Ukraine
Durchbrüche gelingen werden die Frage
ist wie viele Reserven die Ukraine noch
hat in dem Moment wo ein Durchbruch
gelingt um den Durchbruch dann zu nutzen
und Gebiete zu befreien
die beste Unterstützung die wir leisten
können ist uns auch langfristige
systematische Unterstützung einzustellen
das wird der Ukraine eine Grundlage
geben da weiter voranzugehen trotz aller
Probleme bleibe ich optimistisch
das ist ein gutes Schlusswort vielen
Dank Nico lange dass Sie wieder bei uns
im Stream waren und ähm auch an euch und
Sie liebe Userinnen und User danke schön
lange genau und an Sie und Euch liebe
Userin und User danke fürs kommentieren
danke dass ihr dabei wart bis zum
nächsten Mal tschüss